là vous savez là je prends une décharge
énergie pendant trois mois au moins de
voir le sourire des enfants de voir
qu'ils vont pouvoir s'éclater au ping
[Musique]
moi j'ai participé à deux Jeux de la
Francophonie la première fois à Niamey
en 2005 avec l'équipe de France la
deuxième fois au Liban 4 ans plus tard
avec l'équipe du Cameroun
liamé ça a été vraiment quelque chose
qui a changé ma trajectoire de vie à
l'époque j'étais en équipe de France
avait des revêtements de manière
illimité j'étais sponsorisée etc et j'ai
eu la chance de rencontrer les
homologues nigériens qui eux n'avait
même pas de raquettes pour compétir la
table c'était en bord de route sans
filet j'ai pris un bel électrochoc je
suis rentré en France j'ai créé mon
association pink sans frontières et
depuis plus de 15 ans maintenant je
parcours le monde et particulièrement
l'Afrique pour essayer de donner des
équipements faire des formations etc et
ça c'est grâce au jeu ça m'a aussi
ouvert l'esprit ça m'a ouvert le champ
des possibles c'est souvent la première
grosse compétition internationale quand
on est jeune pour moi c'était c'était le
cas j'étais assez jeune j'avais 17-18
ans quand j'ai participé le premier jour
de la Francophonie donc oui c'est
important c'est important d'être là en
tant qu'ambassadrice des jeux et c'est
aussi important de mener une action
concrète et c'est ce qu'on fait ce matin
en leur du matériel mais il y en a qui
arrive sans raquette sans short son
t-shirt donc oui c'est nécessaire de
faire ces dons pour qu'ils puissent
compétir et avoir une belle expérience
des jeux
c'est important c'est même indispensable
en fait d'événements les filles là c'est
sûr c'est leur première compétition
internationale elle va prendre beaucoup
de choses dans tes états mais je pense
aussi en termes d'ouverture d'esprit et
de possibilités dans la vie elle veut
rencontrer des personnes d'autres pays
avec des parcours différents et elles
vont se rendre compte que tout est
possible enfin en tout cas je l'espère
et je vais être là pour essayer de leur
rappeler à chaque instant moi je leur
souhaite d'aller plus loin possible dans
le sport mais aussi dans leur vie et de
trouver un équilibre et les jeux c'est
vraiment ça surtout encore une fois avec
cet équilibre entre la culture et le
sport mais ça ouvre c'est une ouverture
d'esprit incroyable en fait ça et je
pense que ça va beaucoup leur apporter